experts in south africa say the surge in
covert 19 infections is the highest
they've seen since the start of the
pandemic
and they blame the latest and possibly
most contagious variant omicron they
want us that
the variance would generally be more
transmissible
but
most of the time they would be less
severe
today as we enter the fourth wave with a
new variant
we can see confirmation of this warning
while people from this and other
countries in southern africa are facing
international travel bans lockdown
restrictions in south africa are at
their lowest
the government is instead urging people
to get vaccinated
so far 42
of adults have received a jab with
hospital admissions mainly dominated by
those who are not vaccinated
and young people below the age of 40
most of whom are not vaccinated
at this stage we can say that even in
counting
which accounts for 72 to 80 percent of
the new daily infections
we have not yet reached threatening
stages in terms of our hospital capacity
and the new hospital admissions
the government says it has enough
resources to deal with the outbreak even
in one of the worst-hit provinces
haoteng
the latest statistics show daily
infections are growing
and health workers are also concerned
about the high number of children under
five years old who've been hospitalized
the phenomenon of
young children younger age groups as
well as pregnant women having increased
infection is currently being
investigated we are hoping that in the
coming weeks we'll be able to also give
reasons for why this particular
cohort of patient is having increased
infection but officials hope that while
the new variant appears highly
transmissible it can be managed
the government says it will continue
door-to-door campaigns and community
awareness programs to try to convince
people to get a jab health experts say
the number of people dying from covert
19 has remained low because of
vaccinations and right now one in four
people tested for covet 19 in south
africa are recording positive
familia miller al jazeera johannesburg